just before the virus struck just before
in 2019 I played in St Louis I played
Liam in two matches in two games uh
classical chess and okay he does play a
direct move and I noticed as well in
both of those games he was outplaying me
and just at the moment where he should
take a step off the accelerator and just
slowly maneuver then he kind of broke
through and just forced to draw so oh he
could have just kept the pressure he
doesn't like the tension necessarily and
wow there has been a big transition
because just like the last game one of
the queens has been sacrificed and this
time it's magnus's Queen and Magnus is
going to try and build a fortress it's
like a mirror image of the previous game
we have to jump in Black now is material
down so this is the current position but
if we jump back Liam didn't spend much
time before cashing in on the material
taking this Pawn now the White Knight
had to be captured it's too strong and
after Bishop takes Knight using this pin
white is winning material so uh Bishop
takes Bishop happened the black queen
dropped off the board and if we do a
quick count here just like the last game
it's queen versus